hello good people of the internet John
Perry here and this is my science versus
the Ark Encounter halftime special so
I've done three videos so far and I've
got at least three more to make but
before continuing and doing those those
videos I wanted to just do a little bit
of follow up one of my favorite
podcasters is darren naish he has a
podcast called the zoo podcast which you
should definitely be listening to if you
are at all interested in evolution or
tetrapod zoology darren is a
paleontologist and he runs that podcast
with artists John Conway John Conway
does paleo art for the most part you
know every time they do a podcast people
will comment on it and sometimes people
will be upset with some of the things
that they said and so they'll have a
follow-up segment they call it the fu
segment so I'm gonna I'm gonna do a
little fu segment a little follow-up
segment here and I also want to take a
little bit of time to talk about Ken Ham
and why it is that I think that he's
doing the things that he does so that's
what I'm gonna do today my first
follow-up is you know one of the most
common YouTube comments that I've been
getting on this series is why don't you
make more of these Jon why don't you
hurry up and make more science versus
the Ark Encounter videos we love them
and thank you I am flattered it is a
little bit slow making these videos and
the reason for that is that you know I
was I kind of have a soft spot for young
earth creationists I was raised with not
full-on young earth creationist beliefs
but heavily leaning towards young Earth
Creationism and I just yeah I'm just
kind of sensitive to the way in which
people from that world might be
interpreting this I kind of torture
myself trying to be as careful as I
possibly can not to add insult to injury
for people who are receiving this type
of knowledge about how evolution works
and about how people like Ken Ham have
been hiding certain things from them
that's a difficult thing to learn about
and to hear about and to realize and so
I'm being very very careful and because
of that I I double check i triple check
i show these videos to other people and
get their feedback
it's not an easy task to make these
videos because of the I guess the
sensitivities that I have towards
towards my audience but more videos are
coming like I said I've got three more
to do and I'm very excited about them
one of those will be about Mars the Mars
exhibit at the Ark Encounter really
excited about that one now I have
received a lot of angry comments on
these videos and most of them the things
that they're angry about aren't really
legitimate criticisms they're upset
because the knowledge that they're
gaining from these videos is different
than what they thought things were
supposed to be so a lot of those
criticisms I'm not going to engage here
in the follow-up video but there were a
lot of other criticisms that were
legitimate and I do want to talk about
those probably the most common and the
most legitimate criticism that I
received in the comments was underneath
video - where I talked about
Archaeopteryx and I talked about these
special types of fossil beds called
lager Stetten lager Stetten is a german
word and a lot of my German viewers were
upset with my pronunciation I was
calling it lager Stockton's it's longer
Stetten more specifically it's lagers
didn't lagers didn't now most of the
Germans who complained about this
understood that lager Stetten is now
being used in English and so the strange
pronunciation of the s they weren't
expecting me to do the lager Stetten but
they were wanting me to do that last
hard vowel correctly I was saying lager
Staton and it's lager
Stetten so I apologise for my error
please forgive me Germany please forgive
me the second follow-up the second fu
John said I think I should probably
actually talk about here came from a guy
who was very upset with me for the way
that I portrayed the position of John
Reuben John Reuben is a paleontologist
he's one of two paleontologists that
disagrees with the scientific consensus
about the origin of birds and the angry
commenter he said that the way that I
portrayed John Reuben made it sound like
John Reuben doesn't really believe his
own hypothesis but instead just felt
like it was his scientific duty to butt
heads with the scientific consensus to
challenge
the scientific consensus and I went back
and watched the video and the commenter
was right the way that I had ended up
cutting everything before posting it did
make it sound like John Reuben didn't
actually believe in his own hypothesis
John Reuben does believe in his own
hypothesis he definitely believes that
he is right and that all the other
scientists are wrong for a little bit of
clarification I think it'd be good for
me to overview real quickly what John
Reubens position is and what the
scientific consensus is let me just
start out with the scientific consensus
if you go back far enough in the fossil
record there are no dinosaurs there are
no crocodiles instead there is a
primitive group of what we call arcus
ores the consensus is that arcus ores
split in two and one of these groups
ended up getting rise to crocodiles so
the other group gave rise to dinosaurs
then dinosaurs within the dinosaur clade
one group evolved into what we call
theropod dinosaurs these are the
two-legged meat-eaters that usually meat
eaters they're things like t-rex and
velociraptor those are the two really
famous ones from that group from within
this small group of theropod dinosaurs
the scientific consensus is that birds
evolved from that and there's a lot of
evidence to back that up a lot a lot of
evidence I went over some of that in
video to hear John Rubin thinks that the
consensus is a little bit confused he
accepts the idea that yeah if you go
back far enough there's we've got arcus
ores but he thinks that before arcus
ores gave rise to dinosaurs there was
another split and that split so again
this is before dinosaurs even exist yet
that little split that branch of the
arcus or tree that he proposes exists he
thinks that gave rise to birds and he
thinks that animals like velociraptor
are not really dinosaurs he thinks that
they are in this bird line he thinks
that t-rex is a real dinosaur and you
know most scientists would put t-rex and
velociraptor as being fairly close
relatives they're both theropod
dinosaurs John Rubin no he believes that
velociraptor and what the rest of us are
calling bird-like dinosaurs he thinks
those are Arco sores they are not
dinosaurs that they split before
dinosaurs even became a thing
and he believes that the similarities
that we see between things like
velociraptor and t-rex he thinks that
those are just a coincidence
that's John Reubens position I don't see
a whole lot of evidence to support that
John Reuben believes that he will
eventually have enough evidence to
convince the world that he is correct
and that everybody else is wrong but
he's not there yet he hasn't been able
to do that successfully I've seen his
work I've read his papers and to me I
don't find them convincing but that is
his position so there we have it that
that wraps up the follow-up the fu John
segment of today's video recently I have
been thinking a lot about the motives of
young earth creationists like Ken Ham
I've had a lot of people comment and say
that they believe that Ken Ham is lying
to people and they believe that he is
lying to people because he wants money
and he's found that being a young earth
creationist and selling lies to young
earth creationists is easy money that
these people are somehow really gullible
and he's exploiting them I do not think
that that is the case I do think that
Ken Ham is deliberately misleading his
own audience and for those of you that
are look shocked by that statement and
you want evidence go back and watch
video 3 of science versus the Ark
Encounter in that video I go through and
we look at one of the plaques at the Ark
Encounter and we break it down claim by
claim by claim and we talk about the
things that Ken Ham is doing there some
of the claims that he makes are false
and if you say something that's false
it's quite possible that you're just
confused
right but Ken Ham also uses a lot of
what we call half-truths and they're
extremely well-crafted half-truths and
if you're going to create a half-truth
you say something that is technically
true but extremely misleading in order
to craft a really good half truth you
have to understand what the full truth
is and then you have to deliberately
craft that half truth so that you can
deliberately mislead your own audience
so Ken Ham is using tactics that I would
say are definitely dishonest you know if
you don't want to say that their lies
flat out lies they're there at least
definitely dishonest but why
what are his MO
as I mentioned money has been suggested
and I think it's fair to say that Ken
Ham is making a good living I don't know
what his personal finances are but he is
extremely good at raising money he
raised a lot of money to build the Ark
Encounter and I'm sure that he's kept a
little chunk of that but I don't think
the main purpose of Ken hams ministry is
to make money and to exploit people to
make money to mislead and exploit your
own audience for money that really takes
a special kind of monster and I don't
think Ken Ham is that kind of monster he
is being dishonest but I think he's
doing it for a very different reason if
we get on Ken hams website and you read
about his beliefs you will find that Ken
Ham believes in a literal heaven and
hell he thinks that people will be
consciously tortured or rewarded for
eternity after they die and he believes
that the only way to go to heaven to be
rewarded versus tortured is to accept
Jesus Christ as your Savior now those
two doctrines I would say are fairly
common among Christians a lot of
Christians hold those beliefs to one
degree or another there are some
Christian groups that aren't so sure
about the hell part the Book of
Revelations is where we really hear
about the kind of torture and torment
that goes on in Hell and the Book of
Revelations by some people some
Christian thinkers is thought to be more
more of an allegory than literal truth
before the most part I would say that
most Christians believe in a heaven and
hell and most Christians believe that
Jesus Christ is the way to go to heaven
but Ken Ham has an extra belief that
helps justify being dishonest and that
is he believes that the theory of
evolution leads people away from Jesus
and he believes that the theory of
evolution is false he thinks that it's
one of these scientific theories that
will eventually get turned over with
more evidence so he believes it's false
and he believes it's currently having
its you know day in the Sun it will
someday be turned over but he doesn't
know how to turn it over himself and so
the next best thing that he can do is
lie about it to stop people from being
led away from Jesus that might seem
weird like why would you lie why would
you resort to lying but if you if you
take a more practical example like
let's just pretend for a moment that we
are living in Nazi Germany
Lagos Tipton Lagos Tipton and you're a
German you're not keen on this whole
Nazi thing and you have some really good
neighbors that you really care about who
happened to be Jewish and the Nazis are
coming by your door and they're asking
you where your Jewish neighbors are you
know where they are but you don't want
the Nazis to find out I think that
almost all of us even those of us that
really care about honesty would say that
it's okay to lie in this situation when
you look at Ken hams belief system all
of these beliefs together that I've
listed off here and by the way the the
the last two I kind of had to piece
together from watching multiple talks of
his he does not have that explicitly
written that I could find on his website
when we take all these beliefs together
as one we realize that in Ken hams mind
there is good moral justification for
lying to his own audience about the
theory of evolution
he literally believes that he is saving
people from an eternity of torment and
torture in hell he is not the amoral
sociopath exploiting his audience for
money like some people think that he is
now some of you might disagree with me
you might think that I'm way off the
mark but I find this way of thinking to
be extremely enlightening that helps
tell us what we might be able to do to
make teaching evolution easier Ken house
not the only person that shares these
this special set of doctrines there are
a lot of Christians that are very
disturbed by the theory of evolution
they really do think that it is going to
lead them or their children away from
Jesus Christ and they think that that
they or their children will then burn in
hell for time and all eternity and this
is a this fear is very real for the
people that believe these things and
understanding that helps us understand
what we can do as science educators to
help people overcome this barrier if you
are a teacher and you notice that one of
your students is having this issue just
let them know that according to official
polls there are hundreds of thousands of
Christians out there that have found a
way to accept the science of evolution
while also maintaining their religious
beliefs for people that are very set
like Ken Ham that information might not
be very helpful but for a student that
actually might be a really good piece of
information anyway those were my
thoughts and I'm just really happy to be
able to get on here and do this little
halftime special with you do some follow
up tell you about these things I've been
thinking about as far as Ken Ham goes
and the motives of creationism if you
have enjoyed this video make sure to
subscribe to my youtube channel and
click the little bell icon that will
make sure that you get to see the next
Ark Encounter videos that I produce so
long for now stay curious
[Music]
loggers did
[Music]
lager stable lager statement
[Music]
lavash dip